[Music]
all right people we are live on the
YouTube I believe you know that I'm Dave
Rubin and this is a very special episode
of the Rubin report you know we're doing
this live stream thing now we just got
all the technology in the new studio
here we can now live stream to YouTube
and to Facebook and to periscope in a
couple other places and we've got a few
other tricks up our sleeve but today
we're going directly to YouTube on this
just a quick little recap before I bring
on my guest today I've done two
interviews today that I think sort of
get to the heart of everything that I
kind of do that I'm very excited about
it so I usually don't tease the
interviews before we release them but
I'll do that today so this morning I had
Glenn back in here which was really
great you know he's a he's an
interesting guy for a million reasons
even just tweeting about him this
morning
half the people immediately hate him
half the people loved them half the
people just send me pictures of him
snorting Cheetos weird stuff but we had
a really really great discussion about
liberty and individualism and and sort
of common ground and can some of us who
don't agree on every little thing
politically come together to form this
new center hint I think the answer is
yes and then I just interviewed a really
fascinating guy by the name of Flemming
rose and if you don't know who he is you
at least know his work because he was
the editor of the Danish newspaper that
published the Mohammed cartoons back in
2005 which caused sort of worldwide
mayhem and 200 dead people and and we
talked had a great discussion about free
speech and religion and secularism and
all that good stuff so for those of you
watching this right now if you are in
the LA area I'm actually going to be
speaking at UCLA tomorrow Wednesday
night with Fleming Rose and Steve
Simpson from the Iran Institute and it's
open for students at UCLA and for
regular citizens so come and come and
say hi and I spoke at Portland State
University this weekend which was
fantastic with christina hoff sommers
and people go Xion and it was just great
400 kids that wanted
to talk about freedom and free speech
and it was wonderful and they even came
they cancelled the protest they said we
were fascists and then and then the
anti-fascist didn't show up I guess they
were playing video games or something
anyway the reason we're doing this live
today is because of this executive order
that Trump signed in the last couple
days which everyone is calling a Muslim
ban I have the actual text of the whole
thing right here I have read it it's a
couple pages long I've read the whole
thing I shot my direct message for
tomorrow which will be for our episode
with Glenn Beck it has the entirety of
my thoughts on the executive order and
all that but I thought what we could do
today because I wanted to get a little
ahead on this is talk to my to my friend
and now three-time Rubin report guest I
think he's only the second three timer
faisal saeed al Muhtar in new york
how are you brother hey Dave how are you
what's that the new studio oh thank you
you know we got to do this live I think
you're gonna be in LA in a couple weeks
right yeah hopefully in a while it has
been a while all right so here's how I
want to start I'm gonna give a brief
intro and then I want you to tell the
story of Faizal so you are a refugee you
are an actual Iraqi refugee you came to
America about three years ago I believe
you have a green card right now we've
become good friends
I consider you one of the stalwart
fighters for Western secular values
dealing with the difficult issues of
Islamism and the difference between
criticizing ideas and people all of the
stuff that I know my audience cares
about but for the people that don't know
who you are
let's let's put a face on what's going
on here before we get to the order
itself tell me a little bit about
yourself well so I've been here four
years
arrived in March 2013 so yeah so we're
the stars I was born right after the
first the first Iraq war
so I'm quite
that most people expect us live my
childhood under Saddam Hussein and then
the US intervention and followed by the
the civil war between the Sunni and Shia
factions I start kind of my kind of
motion to activism started around the
first Iraqi elections 2005 when I saw
the rise of sectarianism around there
and then the sectarian language
especially in the rise of sectarian
parties that eventually ruled the
country so I was I was raised in a
liberal Muslim household that may sound
an oxymoron for some of the people but I
do believe that that thing actually
exists so can you describe what that
means actually if you live in a liberal
Muslim household in Iraq what does that
actually mean
yeah myself very lucky in that regard so
my dad studied my dad I think my mom as
well they both studied in the United
Kingdom and my dad is a medical doctor
but mom was a lawyer and I was mostly I
mean the toaster had most relationship
with when it comes to intellectual
conversations was my dad so his view is
that he is a Muslim some extent
practicing has his doubts and he said
that faith is not something to be
opposed so I want you as my son my
youngest son faced off with our two
reads and took the floor and if you want
to be a Muslim be a Muslim if you don't
want to be a Muslim that's fine you are
my son I'll always get all of you so
yeah by the time I twelve saturating I
think I mentioned that previous show
that's we think about different
religions and so on and it didn't make
sense at all and I told my dad that this
actually does not make sense and even
though it's a Muslim himself said okay
that's fine I'm glad as long as you're
intellectually honest with yourself so
that's kind of what I and that's I mean
I mean that actually may sound like
liberal even compared to United States
I assume that that idea of being raised
in such families so so I was raising
this background and then the moment
what's kind of a bubble to say the least
so I go outside the house and then
there's like a Clash of Civilizations
between the kind of conservative quite
hypocritical society in Arakan and and
as a result I start getting some threats
and and so on from malicious because at
the time in 2005 2006 2007 the people
film with al Qaeda kind of took over
some parts of West Baghdad there's not
to cover them like al Qaeda Isis now
takes over Mosul and stuff but but in
terms of like the you see like Al Qaeda
fighters walking around that you see
like some dead bodies that I had to walk
on going to school and I saw like people
getting killed in front of my eyes and
so on so that's I still remember like
one of the first weeks in my high school
age when Al Qaeda attacked the police
station in front of my school and like
most of the class were destroyed so fast
forward to - to come up to a bit modern
time in 2007 my eldest brother summer
was going to work with three of his
friends and he was stopped by a false
checkpoint of al Qaeda and they
kidnapped him and we didn't know what
happened he just disappeared and and
some of his a friend said that he was
kidnapped by militia Qaeda and it took
us months and months and months and my
mom and my dad always like he renews
that all we found him over there bla bla
bla so eventually the area that was my
brother was kidnapped
rocky police I think they were smote
area as well
five figures out they all kinda people
and then they showed a picture of my
brother and one of the people said that
yes I killed the guy and then they
showed the picture of his three friends
within also that same year that was the
end of 2007 al Qaeda took came to my
cousin's shop which is kind of like a
deli
like he sells groceries and stuff and
they came and and they shot him and
killed him
so things were all bubbling up I've lost
some friends all of that and situation
what kept getting worse and worse I left
Iraq in 2009 I just trying to just
escape my life and well the easiest
countries for
got you at the time was Lebanon because
Lebanon allows if you have like a
thousand dollars you show it that the
entry there they give you like a sister
visa and I was supposed to apply to the
UK and they rejected me three times one
after the other as they have like also
out kinds of regulations they were
asking for thousands of dollars in the
savings account and stuff and I was just
like just escaping like al-qaeda killing
me okay let's just let's just pause
there for a second because it almost
sounds like there's a certain degree of
bribery I guess is the best way to put
it
that you have to pay to get into Lebanon
and then you were gonna have to pay
again to get transit yesica lee to the
UK that's why you see many Saudis
walking around London and here in
Washington New York and Los Angeles or
you live because they have the money
right so then as a result also Lebanon
was bubbling up and there was lots of
suddenly a conflict happening there and
I was also afraid for my life because
I'm foreigner to some extent so I I said
okay in Malaysia they help they give a
kind of British education over there so
I went there and I applied for UNF CR
the United Nation Committee for Refugees
and then I applied in denial at the
United States in 2013 within that period
of struggle I generally been a writer
Muslim kind of a small blogger I also
started the global sacred human stage
which eventually became of a largest in
the world that advocate for secularism
and so on which is kind of that that's
kind of my claim to fame and yeah and
Here I am so that's kind of my my small
my small part of a you know and people
probably have seen me in case they watch
some of the media and the news and
social media so yeah and you you gave us
a real truncated version of it there but
you know it when we post this once it's
not live anymore we'll have the link to
our original sit down where you
extrapolate a little bit on some of the
specifics so okay you get to America and
I know you fairly well right now you
stand for what I think are pretty much
the right things whether we agree on
every little thing is irrelevant to me
but you stand for
for secularism and Western values and
decency human decency and liberty and
all that stuff when you got here what
was it like being an Iraqi in America
well I didn't tell you with the funny
story so I loved it in Los Angeles what
I've arrived United States and the first
thing I went to was down I thought I
loved it in Mexico so my first post in
America was what the [ __ ] did I just
loved in Mexico like what did I go to
the wrong flight so yeah Houston Los
Angeles and it was naturally interesting
so anyway but I moved to Texas where my
brothers lived and I am very impressed I
mean I love I mean I've been to 40
states since I arrived through this
country and cuz giving off talks and
lectures around the country and so on
and I'm very impressed I mean United
States I mean I didn't expect the other
states as big as it is it seems like
it's really big and it's beautiful I
mean I have a very beautiful hospitality
story that the family in Washington DC
invited me to first celebrate the first
fourth of July in my in the United
States that was 2013 then I consider
right now to be my American family so
they invited me to Washington and then
we celebrate the fourth of July and then
after I moved to Washington DC I stayed
I lived with them for quite a while and
they are treated me Bigley yeah I've
seen kind of a face of a face of America
that is very hospitable very friendly
very lovely had some bad interactions
here and there are like some freaking
Hasidic Jew in New York telling me that
I come from a dirty land and I'm
responsible for Jewish genocide and so
on they're like some burger place saying
me go back to Iraq go back to Iraq and
all of that [ __ ] but in general I mean
looking at the big picture I would say
the United States showed me a very
friendly face
people at least that bubble I live in of
people who think kind of like us and
mostly liberal or center left center
right and so on except me as you just
beautifully said that you consider be a
fighter for liberal values and human
rights and so on and so so yeah I mean I
mean I don't I mean I consider United
States right now to be my home I am very
lucky to be here very lucky to have been
accepted and that is kind of the result
why I've kind of added of you have
noticed in the past three days is that
I've been very critical of all the
chompin because I know I mean I don't
consider myself as special to some
extent I because I know a lot of the
liberal amazing people with in Arakan
Saudi Arabia and so on and I would love
them to have this experience I would
love them to see that there is another
side of the West then I mean my first
experience with the United States
probably thought about it before was to
seeing a u.s. tank going to the front of
my house that's the first time I meet an
American right that's not a great intro
exactly and I'm so like and then the war
and they're like all of what I've seen
is that u.s. people sitting in Humvees
and firing bullets at extremists and
al-qaeda coming in and they are firing
rockets so this is kind of my experience
with the kind of the and obviously I
mean I assume some of them are good
people but but I mean generally we have
in US Army's US Army and they have to do
motor said but like this is I'll tell
you before and in Iraq and they were all
so friendly receptive that's kind of
like it was mostly a military but coming
here and seeing the civilian life and
seeing what Americans are like changed
my view about lots of things construct
as someone who grew up in the Saddam and
all of the u.s. proplica Iraqi
propaganda the Saddam against the u.s.
being the Satan and so on my experience
coming to America and seeing the
different cultures and living now and
one of the most diverse cities in the
world kind of open my eyes and that's
kind of motivates me to always
constantly defend the United States
whether in public for
or private farms or even defend it in
any way possible working counter
extremism how can we defeat Isis in all
of these groups that I would like as
much as possible to get this opportunity
given to as many people as possible who
are escaping than jerkily one in the
same situation as I am and yes I've been
very critical of the ban may be so let's
let's pause let's pause there for a sec
because I want I want to just do one
other thing before we talk about the
band specifically which is your work
which I know is a little bit in
transition right now but a lot of the
work that you do and by the way you're
in New York I don't know if we mentioned
that earlier you said one of the most
diverse places but just FYI you are a
Newark a lot of the work that you've
done and that you do is directly related
to helping people in closed societies
you're trying to find the individuals in
these societies that are the most
vulnerable to extremism you're the
atheists the gay people the free
thinkers etc etc and you're trying to
get these ideas to flourish to untie
them from religion is that all fair to
say well to some extent I mean I I serve
myself my work is is a mix of
humanitarianism and also to do damage
control I mean that I think that the
people the voices of the support of
human rights and secularism and all of
the values that we stand for is the best
counter narrative to extremism and and
extremism for me and and obviously being
kind of on the receiving end of
extremism of losing my brother and
losing obviously I have some emotional
reasons why I'm doing I'm doing but but
also rational reasons is that there are
people within these regions in the
middle races this Asia who are living in
these places and let's only have nobody
to help them so I mean I wrote this
article recently about how it's easier
to start a terrorist group in the Middle
East and start a liberal one and one of
the main reasons for that is not just
because of lack of moderates or lack of
liberals and so on is because if you
start a terrorist group let's say in
Iraq and you're a Sunni extremist
you have millions of dollars coming to
you from Saudi Arabia Qatar and so on
you're a Shia militia you get millions
of dollars
coming from Iran but if you are a
liberal who stands for the most of the
values that we stand for you hardly you
work as a taxi driver and could hardly
feed your family and that's that balance
is something that balance is something
that I'm I will say I'm dedicating my
life to change is that this is this is
unfair that for example right Drive
Badawi and as other bloggers are like
just having a blogs on the internet
while like channels like Al Jazeera
Arabic that calls for killing of of
homosexuals and misogyny and all of
these things are saving millions of gas
money got natural gas and oil and and
these are the people that we should help
and I being that privileged in that
regard that I was one of the people who
escaped that part of the wall down
bilingual not bisexual just this is
America dude what's your boat so
bilingual well-connected educated and so
on and I would like to suppress that and
help spreading this idea so you are my
work people deal table suka you must
movement movement org and I'm static by
a new organization IDs Beyond Borders
that's gonna happen in the next few
weeks so this is mostly been around this
kind of ideas that get these people the
best counter-narrative extremists get
the maximum help as possible to defeat
the extremists and that's that's what
I'm mission of my life yeah and by the
way you know some of the work that you
do you know it's nice that you get some
of these public accolades but some of
the work you know there's somebody that
we can't even really go into the story
right now that we've been trying to help
facilitate a freethinker that we've been
trying to get out of Iraq that could be
complicated now because of this whole
executive order so let's shift let's
shift to this thing
so as I said in my direct message that I
taped today and it'll be up tomorrow I
read it I actually read it I know you
read it as well most of the people that
are online and on television I don't
think they actually read it they just
start screaming about it so we can go
through every point in there if you want
we can we can talk about the parts that
are more personal to you because the
green card for you is a very important
piece the first part that I just want to
put out there and may
you disagree with me and feel free
obviously is that in my view this is not
a Muslim ban because if you took the top
five countries that Muslim people live
in including Indonesia and Pakistan
there's over 750 million Muslims that
this a better exempt from this that
aren't on the list now we could argue
whether the list is idiotic because
Saudi Arabia is not on there in 19 of
the 21 I Jack errs from 9/11 and weren't
on there Pakistan's not on there etc etc
Turkey's not on there but do you think
it's fair to say that this is not a
Muslim ban no no I think I think it is I
mean it's more complicated so so for
example I mean within for example Iraq
or some other countries people who are
of Israeli citizenship are not allowed
to enter Iraq right yeah but Iraqi Jews
are American Jews are allowed to enter
Iraq because America but so somebody can
say that that the banning against
Israeli citizens coming to Iraq is a
Jewish ban somebody can interpret that
as a Jewish ban which is partially true
right I mean Israel is the quotient
cause the Jewish state and and it to ban
that people come from Israel so so here
is why I do consider it partially to be
a Muslim ban is first of all they put
the caveat over there saying that
religious minorities are exempt so when
you are talking about Muslim majority
countries and religious minorities are
exempt what who are you actually talking
about you're talking about Muslims so it
is it is a partially Muslim ban on these
countries it's not that it's not an
absolute Muslim ban in which which the
reason I think where the Muslim ban hash
that came from is I think is a result of
the Trump speech after the San
Bernardino attack when he said that I am
Joel J Trump I'm gonna make a complete
shutdown of Muslims when they saw this
thing coming up they will be like okay
he said that in his campaign and now
he's saying that religious minorities
are not part of a list of Muslim
dominated countries therefore it's a
Muslim ban I think that obviously this
has been hijacked the cause has been
hijacked by
people that we know and like care and
their allies and and their useful idiots
on the left right who will all make them
will make it all about open borders and
how Islam is a peaceful religion and how
there is no problem of extremism of
numbers of communities and we should
like let them all it obviously just like
everything is now being hijacked I mean
I would like the woman's March I was
there for like supporting Planned
Parenthood I consider myself a big
supporter of and I'm very pro-choice
myself and I so like people like
defending the hijab and defending like
which is a misogynistic simple right
this is like their I literally saw a
woman with like wearing a bra and
holding the the symbol of hijab the the
poster of Asia and you were like you are
wearing a bra and you're holding
something of modesty culture like shoot
me in the [ __ ] face right like so
there is so there's always obviously
there is this hijack that happens and
almost unfortunately every cause I mean
you we're talking about like you and I
are very much against the regressive
left and at the same time you have like
[ __ ] neo-nazis against the regressive
left right so like every cause that may
may start for the right reasons and and
and and so on unfortunately gets
organized or gets hijacked by the people
who are the most organized and
unfortunately people like care and estar
and all of the Muslim organizations or
some of them are Islamist hijack the
cause and turned it into oh this is anti
Islam and and there is no problem with
Islam and and everything is is lesson
compile and have orgies right so like
this is this kind of this kind of but
that doesn't mean that the main outer
selector that there is no actual
criticism of the of the band itself and
and and I have been a victim of it I
mean I I was supposed to have multiple
international talks oh well it's all
focused on about ground counter
extremism and and and the same job that
I do I have event with our friend ala
recipe in Toronto and yes and then I
have a close
a friend who went a circus family
members went to Iraq to visit the a dead
relative and now we told off she gonna
be able to make it better or not so it
is a blanket ban on on anybody who who
is Muslim or looks Muslim or has a
Muslim name and so on sorry and also it
sends a signal but very bad signal that
so so I think there was a Republican
senator of the committee services made a
very great he said that there are two
people who are wrong in this debate that
the number one are the ones who say
jihadism has nothing to do with Islam
these are people are completely wrong
the Obama administration and their
fellow allies within the lifetime public
publicize this idea that like we are our
enemy is countering violent extremism
and even though that they all avoid like
brown people with named Mohammed an ally
in there but the name is countering
violent extremism an echo are you joking
okay so yeah so there is this part of
that a great foreign policy with the
administration has been far from courage
and I've been critical of it all all
since I came to America in for a kept up
okay and there's the other side who
think Coolidge I think they think and I
wish to be wrong I don't wish to be
wrong is that they don't really see any
differentiation whatsoever between the
likes of me and the likes of Osama bin
Laden because we both have Muslim names
or Arabic names and were both of brown
people coming from that part of the
world and it's their people and so on so
so I and that sends a signal so so
within the left and the regressive light
an organization is that Aslam has
nothing to do with your handsome and so
on and within the out right or the far
right whatever you want to call it or
the Trump is done as I like to call it
is that it is every every Middle Eastern
and every Muslim Kamaka from there is
some source of a potential jihadis or a
potential terrorists right and I think
that within all this craziness I'm
really hoping that there is some kind of
a middle ground and some balance that we
can have and I don't see that from ban
is part of that balance right okay so
let's let's pause because you gave me a
lot there so first off I mean
man you're saying everything I believe I
don't think you said one thing there
that I don't agree with and it's been my
mission now for the last two years to
try to show people that there is a
difference between this regressive
ideology and horrific authoritarian
ideology and that that most of us are in
the middle and I think we're making a
lot of good headway there which is why
we have so many allies now including Ali
Riza me who you just mentioned and Sarah
hater and Sam Harris and Christina of
summers and the Holga Julie and other
people from all different walks of life
so I don't want to get too lost in the
Muslim ban word but I'm glad that we at
least made the distinction between we're
acknowledging it's not all Muslims there
might be some piece of this that is
intended to be bigotry bigoted and maybe
three months after the 90-day review
they're gonna say all Muslims in which
case of course I would be against that
what do you think about the seven
country part because Saudi Arabia is not
on there how yeah well I mean as a
matter of principle I don't believe in
the concept of collective guilt I don't
believe in the concept that we should
punish countries or a group of people on
the actions of even whether it was the
minority or the majority because there
are as I said there are tons of people
like so even in countries like Saudi
Arabia which is I'm probably gonna be
banned from from life right sort of the
most extreme I would not go to you're
not vacationing in Saudi Arabia the two
of us yeah but I'm also like if there is
a ban on Saudi Arabia I would be one of
the first people are protesting for it
because I won't drive Badawi who is one
of my dearest friends one of the biggest
liberal advocates to still have a chance
to computerize states in Pakistan which
is also a country ravaged by extremism
and and deplorable Taliban people and
and so on at the same time there are
other ways we come from Pakistan sorry
they come from Pakistan I still want to
allow for it I am all for restrictions
like I mean I support the idea of it
extreme Vedic I mean especially from
countries that are thrilled with
extremism
that's that should be common sense that
the people
coming from Fallujah Iraq have a better
chance of becoming terrorists then
people come and go from I don't know
Norway or like that's just common sense
I mean this is the shatrah common sense
for even supposedly liberals who should
actually adhere to this concept so I
mean I definitely do not want the Ness
Muslim extremist I mean just just two
years ago I had an event regarding
Islamophobia here in New York and we
know in New York we also have the Book
of Mormon which is but but but we have
the debate of Islamophobia and literally
there were people
NYPD escorted me to enter the event and
to live the event and even when I go
have a cigarette there is some security
guy going outside with me to help me
smoke a cigarette and I was like in
America in New York City of all places
we are afraid to have an event about
Islamic extremism or Islamophobia and so
on then what the hell we should do it
right I mean if in your [ __ ] do it do
it
what are gonna do it in like couple so
there is definitely the issue of Islamic
extremism and Islam is definitely an
issue that has to be extreme
measurements and one of the proposals
back there seven countries stuff and one
of the countries the country that I come
from Iraq is that in which the United
States came to this country and there
were many Iraqis work with the US Army
as a translators and intelligence and so
on who prove their loyalty to the United
States who prove the royalty to many of
the US Army why not hire some of these
people and make them do the vetting they
understand the language they understand
the culture they have a bit of undergrad
understanding of who's who and then they
can ask the right questions and of all
the seven countries by the way zero of
the refugees have committed the
terrorist act in the United States so
zero is I think that this seven
countries even though they say it was
taken from about ministration and so on
is first of all it's a place of great
concern obviously because there's a lot
of instability happening in Yemen
ultimate stability happening in Iraq and
Syria because some parts of Iraq are
still under the control of Isis and some
part of Sierra's the control Isis yes
there has to be a special verdict I've
read it through that fitting I was when
I applied tonight as refugees they asked
me lots of questions then I have to
write lots of things and it took me
years before I came to United Stated
and that was during the court record the
apologist Obama administration right
that's that what the Trump is talking
about as them being weak and so on I
came into the Obama administration and
it was already so difficult for Iraqis
to come from that made must be there
like an extra layer why not should
people be get asked if they pray five
times a day and and whatever maybe that
should be something that maybe they
should consider but that doesn't even
say about anything because there are
people who pray five times a day or
probably support the existence of Israel
and and and I don't know that they they
drink on Thursday so that so but yes so
you're saying you're saying you should
judge people individually you're not as
a collective I think exactly yes we
should take people case by case scenario
yeah and so understanding that some
countries are wantem just than others
and at the same time have the case by
case scenario in order for us to defend
the real people that we want as allies
and not to send the signal that
everybody who's coming from there
somehow a potential terrorist or trying
to get us or trying to steal their jobs
I think there is a balance of compassion
at the same time security national
security it doesn't have to be I either
have to be tough and screw everybody or
I have to be in ablest or denialists
open borders clown there is there is no
auspicious right well that's in my
direct message which we're gonna post
tomorrow that's what I said it's like
we're fighting between people are saying
we should have no borders which is
national suicide that's not what a
country is yeah and then people are
saying we shouldn't have any immigrants
which is the most aunt
it's the antiquated antithesis of what
America actually is so I'm curious if if
this ban which we now know is a 90 day
temporary ban while they figure out the
vetting process right
we shall see nine okay yeah but if he
had said we're not putting any specific
countries out here but we're pausing the
entire thing no we're not singling out a
specific country but for 90 days
we are pausing this except for the most
extreme individual cases where someone
might be killed tomorrow or something
like that
would you have basically been okay with
that idea where we're not singling out
the countries but just so we can figure
out what's going on which obviously a
lot of people want and I think you're
hinting is a or I think you said is
basically a legitimate argument to
figure out what's going on with betting
would you have basically been okay with
that yeah well I mean terms and
conditions apply I mean there are so
many people right now who are on the
pipeline of coming to the United States
as refugees and immigrants and many of
these people I mean for example like
being when I came here to the United
States and they said I will be accepted
at the next and for me because I'm a
single man they probably make it until
the last and they tell me you're going
to be accepted so let's say some people
are already told them that they are
works they were accepted as refugees to
come to United States and then they have
houses and they have stuff that they
have to sell or whatever like whatever
jobs that they have to quit and so on
it's I think that to say that okay we're
going to delay you for the next I don't
know 90 days until we figure out what
the hell is going on is you know also
like I mean within that the hard periods
they're going to be lots of students I
mean I'm listening lots of stories of
students who kept United States and
their scholarship and stuff and they're
gonna come here they're gonna study and
most of them gonna come back except what
the notion is that they could have stay
here and plan for asylum actually most
of them want to come back and develop
Iraq and the countries that we want to
get or extremism from and something like
this I think if it's gonna be done
within a gradual level and it's gonna be
done intelligently and I think we all
acknowledge that there is a problem
there is a problem within jihadism
there's a bravura slums and I think that
except that the denialists that are not
called it just like the Kalama climate
change skeptics like the banners there
is the Islamist denialist here
well done technology discipline called
as long as ooh unless other than these
people most people acknowledge that
there is a problem within the Muslim
world when far as the Korea for example
called a concert of extremism Akram did
the Muslim Oh every I mean most people
acknowledged that the question is how
can you deal with it and the same time
you don't antagonize the people that we
walk we want as allies because what I'm
afraid of
in something that complete ban and so on
it's gonna turn the conversation as a
war between the East and the West and a
clash of civilization and Dave Ropin the
guy who grew up in New York and vessel
or grew up in Baghdad are enemies
because of the countries they were born
into and this kind of concept of
personalization is gonna empower that
worse people in the universe it's going
to empower the isis's of the world and
it's going to empower their neo-nazis
and their white supremacist of the law
because these and also the lettuce or
source of the world right the ones who
want to utilize all of this discussion
on the advantage so right for the record
should band me on Twitter I was gonna
ask her to come on the show but to have
a discussion with so anyway so like I am
afraid that this kind of language that
Trump administration have used abused
and and the policies that is talking
about it's gonna add I mean it's gonna
disadvantage the best allies that we
have to the fight I mean I remember back
in Iraq in 2007 in which the United
States created this idea called the
search and I said send the search and
there was a guardian or there Petraeus
and he was working with people called
awakening forces the Sunni forces most
of them on quote-unquote moderates more
conservative than I want them to be but
anyway they were our best allies and
there were many areas in which al-qaeda
used to be having safe zones in which
was the United States Army both
alliances with the South the Sunni
Muslims and start defeating al Qaeda al
Qaeda was getting defeated area after
area I mean thanks to President Obama
withdraw the forces scroll the world but
but but a whole other topic that's all
attacked but but the concept of building
alliances with with Muslims and trying
to work out with Muslims to defeat
extremism
I think is a great idea
not to make it into Muslims are
terrorists what people are civilized and
all of this polarized thinking and
eventually what we all getting is more
polarization and more hates and more
divisions and I think that voices like
us and you attacks so much for great
your great show is if you're trying to
prevent that and I think that neither
Trump I don't think Trump as one of the
guys are part of the solution right so I
understand that that people there's a
certain amount of people that no matter
what Trump is gonna do are gonna say
he's up to no good he's up to no good
what I tried to say on Twitter and maybe
I didn't quite get it out perfectly was
that
and it was roads related to you exactly
because I didn't understand this piece
about the green card that I thought that
if they had a full understanding of what
it would do to someone like you
someone that's here via a green card
that is doing such good work for the
fighting of these terrible ideas that
that wouldn't be intentional now it
sounds like at first they were gonna ban
the people with green cards so that yeah
potentially if you left you wouldn't be
allowed to get back in then it sounded
like yes you would be allowed to get
back in
last I heard it's a case-by-case basis
is that right yeah well they said
they're gonna do additional screening
but I have a mind of disagreement with
you maybe it's murder means major
difference who's watching
III I don't think it's well-intentioned
I mean III think that I mean there is
also I mean I don't know that it's
well-intentioned my hope is that it was
it was a missing yeah but you you're
probably right yeah I don't think it is
I mean just like there are people who
say that well like actually some
disagree with them I as well is that
they say like all these Democrats who
are pandering for the Muslims are just
well-intentioned well what if they just
want to get their votes and they're
pandering to them how do you know
they're one of tension or if you have a
PhD in soccer Alice's like nobody knows
I mean I think for the Trump is dumb
people they they just don't care they I
think they love them just don't care
they think that like oh who cares if
there is like Iraqi secular race or
whatever doing the fight these people
are their culture
and there are our enemies I and I hope
to be wrong I would love to be wrong on
this but what I've seen so far is that
what I have seen is mostly that the kind
of like a conversation and debate
between Pamela Geller on one side the
wonderful soul on the other and that is
like doomsday scenario and we're seeing
kind of a doomsday scenario with Donald
Trump and I don't think that that he is
actually a politician I don't think he
just I don't think he has that nuance of
knowledge maybe some people like for
example general mattis with someone I
actually do pleura SPECT and I think
he's very intelligent guide military guy
but at the same time I don't think Trump
understands most of the nuances of the
conversation and also from his previous
conversations about like Islam hates us
like okay that's like a very cliche talk
about the differences here like I don't
think he really understands he sees he
sees Arabs Muslims or these bad guys or
whatever and our people America first
America will get to defend itself I'd of
the key only understand the complexities
of the wall that were facing today yes
so just to be very clear about your
green card situation as it stood right
now potentially you could go give your
talk with Ali rizvi in Canada who's a
Muslim reformer a great great guy but
potentially you could be stopped
you would be we know you would get extra
screening and the risk for you is that
that something goes wrong with the
screening and you can't get back that is
what you could be faced with exactly and
I mean you probably have troubled a lot
and you never know what the officer how
bad he is I mean I mean I've heard
stories I've sent you the article and
NPR
in which some of the officers were
asking the people to sign a form which
is kind of canceled at your green card
form and which people through probably
will file full the form and then their
green card will be forfeited and then
they will not be able to handle the
United States that we good with so
you're gonna be I mean I consulted I had
not consulted good lawyers so far but of
course although with some of my friends
who pretty much 99% advised me not to
leave the country
they're like it's too much higher risk
and even though I told them that all my
speeches that are gonna be contradict
about countering extremism and so on
they said well you're gonna be coming
with a lot or could that officer
immigration officer who doesn't know
what the hell who are you
they're gonna say like face outside aloo
Matar sees the chapel document and sees
your birth of place is Iraq and it's
under seven countries and you're like
okay stand in the line we're gonna check
yourself or they're gonna check whatever
and then you're like oh you mean the
joke about Isis wow you have a member of
Isis and then I don't want them check-in
your phone I mean you send me some funny
stuff about I said if you want to join
Isis change join them because chances
are from within okay and I was banned
from Facebook for thirty days because of
that job so imagine if someone like at
the one harmless security guy sees a
joke like this and you're like all I was
saying that we should join Isis and and
you go back to your your country or
gonna set it to Guantanamo Bay so it's
like it's a very high risk to actually
go because you gotta be you don't know
who's the officer I mean I I've traveled
to Canada back and forth multiple times
and I've had many officers or very
friendly and they're like walk up to
America and whatever but once I also get
like some guy who like I love it I think
he was like hating me he was like what
are you doing what what are you doing
there I'm like what I was having like a
birthday party like what do you think I
was doing it was and and you never know
so sometimes you get a bad officer we're
gonna be like you know what you're from
Iraq I think that you don't deserve to
be here or whatever and and make you
sign a form to forfeit your green card
and then your cos get cancelled and if
you never get to go back to this country
and yeah so it's a very high risk
yeah and that's that's why I wanted to
do this with you today and especially do
it live where I don't have any notes or
anything because you to me are the best
face that we can put on this of whether
it was well-intentioned or not
well-intentioned or whatever we don't
have to split hairs with any of that
stuff it doesn't even matter
but the simple fact is that someone like
you and you are not the only one
like you you're one of a kind but there
are some other people like you that that
you could potentially even at our
Canadian border be stopped and then
potentially have to go back to Iraq
which would literally at this point be a
risk to your life exactly yeah and so I
mean the the with that that's kind of a
major issues that I'm kind of being
stuck in is that and I saw I mean
obviously I still love this country I
would love to live here as much as I
want but I kind of felt really
disappointed that this this kind of a
blanket discrimination I don't really I
mean you know me very well I don't want
to blame the victim cards my whole life
like even though many people like all
your stories is so horrific and you put
it through a lot and stuff and actually
how to talk about my story I don't even
make my story to be the central point of
my life but seeing that kind of
treatment kind of make me felt felt
truly sad made me really felt like a
victim of some sort I mean I like what
did I do to actually just they're
frustrated and but at the same time it's
why it's the individual versus the
collective so I'm curious what would you
say you know my audience yeah I think
pretty well and one of the things that
I'm most proud of is that my audience is
all over the place politically I have
alright people watching I have far-left
progressives watching
I got libertarians and classical
liberals and everybody and I think it's
pretty well mixed across the board on
all that so what would you say directly
to the people that fall a little more in
the in the alt-right category or in the
Trump category that they hear Isis say
you know what we're gonna take advantage
of the refugee situation right we know
Isis is saying this and they've done it
in Europe that we're we want our
fighters to get through these borders
and then people see you know the the
truck thing in was that in France
yeah Berlin and and the theater shooting
and all of the stuff that's happening in
Germany and the rapes that are happening
in Sweden all of that stuff and for even
all of them that I'll give them all the
benefit of the doubt and they'll say
wait a minute
obviously faisal is not like this but
for the people that here
those messages what what would you say
to them about their legitimate concerns
yeah obviously I don't deny their
concerns these concerns are real Islamic
extremism is real concern that I'm not
trying to deny their what I'm trying to
tell them is that by making it making it
a blanket statement or making a blanket
policy like what we had with the term
pack and so on you are obviously there
is no rational reason to join Isis I
mean I've got this wrong man liberals
who say of wicked a bad refugees this
but refugees are joining Isis well
they're actually you're not helping by
saying this [ __ ] because you're saying
you're saying that these people are
actually potential terrorists and if you
just think of them they're gonna join
Isis you're I saw so many celebrity just
huge Twitter following saying this if
you ban them they'll become terrorists
exactly so so the my message to the
regressive left this and all this
Haulover celebrities you're not helping
at all okay
like even with all my disappointment I
will never get a tour Isis I'm getting
like drink margaritas and it's falafels
and probably get stuck in New York and
like I don't know go to Brooklyn like
that's pretty much I would do if I get
stuck in America even with all my
disappointment I'm not getting to Isis
I'm not gonna join a terrorist group
margaritas and falafel does that kinda
makes it like Mexican food so so yeah
Mexican drinks and anyway so what comes
to the outside people and the Trump
supporters and stuff is that when you
are making the general general statement
that all of the people over there are
somehow threats and we have to have bans
and it's we have to make newcombe or
something like all of these comments
that I see on the internet or somebody
like me or other lesbian stuff are kind
of accused of takea that were kind of
lying in the defense of Islam and that
was okay I get it by the way a Twitter
egg did tell me you're a double agent
so if you're a double agent you're real
really good by the way I mean my math
exam smart so I'm just probably right
yeah select someone like this in which
someone like me just because of my
culture of origin and so on is somehow
trying to bring Sharia law to America
and the guise of atheism are you [ __ ]
kidding me like should me anyway so so
this is kind of mentality that like
everybody from there as a threat
everybody from there
we have to be worried about them and so
on this kind of mentality is also not
helping we are we're talking about the
celebrities and the regressive left and
all these people but the other mentality
that the general Isis and both of them
are based on rationality so what I would
ask them is that to look at people like
us and to look at people who are
standing for the values of the US
Constitution and human rights and so on
rather than complaining and putting Pepe
the Frog as your profile picture well
play at least maybe donating your skill
to help some of us or try to suppress
the good words and show that there are
people who are really fighting that for
the same values that you are supposedly
trying to defend a assuming that they
actually believe with liberal values and
human rights and so on assuming I'm I'm
making an assumption here but there so
if you want people who if you want more
faizal's if you want more other recipes
well support people like me and make
them do the fight to actually do the
fight against extremists and then just
like what we had fifty years ago I mean
Iraq you look at the pictures of Iraqi
look at the pictures of Iran you look at
the situation was not as bad as you the
ISIS and stuff has not always been the
case there are be cases within the the
Middle East that now would preserve the
states of concern and so on in which
there were beautiful fashion shows in
Tehran and and women were in the skirts
and back that and there are cinemas well
if we if fact that was the case the 70s
we can make back data great again yeah
as we well should I mean you see those
pictures from what Lebanon was like you
know 30 years ago Lebanon is still
basically what Western eyes compared to
a lot of the rest of them but but you
see pictures especially of Iran and Iraq
and whatever and it's like wow that did
exist people
as Bill Maher would say women don't want
to live in beekeeper costumes they would
rather be in bikinis but I would argue
they should be in whichever one they
want they should just have the choice
they should have the choice and but the
same time it is fair to say that like
these trends of of but workers and stuff
and that's also a message for my liberal
friends these are symbols of misogyny if
you are a feminist and you defend the
right for because the concept behind is
including the hijab is modesty culture
it's modesty culture is that the idea
that men cannot control their lusts and
women have to cover up because if they
don't cover up they're going to be raped
and they're gonna be attacked and that
concepts is has risen up as a result of
so many reasons the Cold War and the
support of the Saudis and stuff but
things can actually I think that with
this with the with the power of
technology with the power of of
connectivity and so on we can actually
experience that conversion back to what
things were before and maybe make them
better
I mean Arab national Arab socialism
which kind of what kind of made some of
that secular building has failed maybe
we need a new system other than national
socialism I think with that with the
power of of technology and the power of
connectivity and education and and so on
I think that these are the people that
we should support and this is where the
some supporters and others should be
focusing more on just to focus on the
negative stuff and generalize it and
make it as their whole situation yeah
well listen I we could go on forever but
I just want to do two more things and
then we'll do this hopefully hopefully
in two or three weeks are gonna be in LA
yeah yeah
so we'll do a live but just two quick
things first off you've hinted at this a
lot and it's obviously been a
through-line of what I've done on this
show but being abandoned by the left
since since they abandoned me in sort of
an ideological sense but they've
abandoned you as a human being can you
just give me like a two-minute feeling
of what happened there and I know we've
talked about this a lot but I just sense
we've texted about this like just an
exhaustion at this point that we tried
so
and it's not just us there's people that
are a lot more influential than both of
us but we tried and I really feel like
we've lost but I do have hope which
you'll get to my next question
yeah I mean so I mean I finish it that I
think the show and also mine was
mentioned it's called the liberal
betrayal the liberal betrayal sorry so I
mean if you take a look at Western
liberal and Hillary cooks supporter and
so on and you ask them about the
questions about do you support same-sex
marriage they support are you pro choice
do you support climate change this
apology
I agree with almost everything like I
agree do you support a fitness for poor
people
I agreed almost everything that
Democrats support when it comes to the
major issues I mean I'm not I'm kind of
right compared to Bernie Sanders and all
of the people on the far left but I
concern myself kind of if you're right
of Bernie you're not see you know so
that being said on the issue of Islamic
extremism you change the subject to so I
mean I've had this debate before I said
what do you call it a public head white
Republican guess guess same-sex marriage
he said I call him a bigot well thank
you for calling 99 percent muscles
bigots and I said no I never said that
so should this kind of I mean there are
two kind of racism happening there are
stresses more flower expectations from
the left and there's racism of higher
expectations from the far right and
which they expect me just because of a
more person I can defeat all of our
extremist extremist not being in Iraq a
refugee with like a limited amount of
funding is that serve as a so the racism
floor expectations I feel I feel that I
have been betrayed by both sides I've
been betrayed by both of the extremes
and obviously I have a lot of following
and there are many people who support me
what I think you are alluding to in an
exponent so yes I mean I feel extremely
betrayed by a lot boy life because I
share so much agreements with them and
seeing that I mean look even within the
last years of the Obama administration I
looked at some of the funding the grants
that he has given to support countering
violent extremism and I saw it many of
them going to Islamist groups who
support Sharia law
so on and you would be like so you're a
Democrat who is a poor separation of
church and state who supports same-sex
marriage why don't you support the same
people who agree with you like why why
do you support people who think that we
should impose the hijab and and and
modesty culture like and that's and why
are liberals secularists in the Middle
East not being funded while you're are
we giving the money at least give it to
the right people so I mean that's
betrayal of continuous betrayal eight
years of the administration
every time I understated award the from
Obama by the way I mean I I'm happy for
many things he's done but at the same
time I would say unfortunately he has
been wrong a lot on that issue of Islam
kiss my lips and president that I would
actually promised an American citizen I
would have voted for Obama but but but
at the same time I feel that look kind
of like make it like you used to love
your ex-girlfriend and she betrays you
and she cheats on you and you feel like
you're being cheated very different than
with the writer I don't have that big of
dislike of the write because I never
considered myself part of the write like
I on some issues maybe but overall I
don't support Sarah Palin and all this
basket of deplorable yes I mean I I
support some of the concepts of the
rights people like James Carr chicken
some conservatives even capitalism but
overall I don't support this kind of
Christian rights nonsense that
unfortunately demented the Republican
Party so I feel extremely betrayed by
the left compared to others yeah okay so
then that brings me to the last thing
which I think you know where I'm going
with this which is that I now firmly
believe and I'm gonna devote myself to
it for at least the next year that the
new center is here I think it's already
here and I think it includes you and I
think it includes Sam Harris and Maajid
Nawaz and Ali Rizvi and many many of you
and Sarah hater and plenty of the other
people I've had on the show and
interestingly I also think it includes
people on the right that we wouldn't
have thought were allies yeah for
example somebody somebody a guy like Ben
Shapiro who you probably would have huge
differences with and maybe this is where
me and you wouldn't totally see eye to
eye but I see him as a little more
libertarian who is not bigoted and I
think we can it does
we also be in the same political party
but I say NewsCenter as people who
really want Liberty and people to be
looked at as individuals and free so
what can we do to push that whether you
agree with me on Van or nots a moot
point but you can I definitely agree
that I mean I I get like I mean
obviously I get lots of hate but at the
same time I get lots of emails of people
who say I love your perspective I'm
tired of this polarization of left or
right I think you make sense and I get
that from people on the right and people
on the left and as I said like there are
many people on the right that I consider
friends people like James Carr chick and
and are in Castelar and others who who I
also consider center-right or
Republicans and probably moderate
Republicans yes of course I would say I
mean depends on what you define as
statement of principles and there is a
growing movement happening there and
there is people who are sick and tired
of both of the polar opposites and they
feel that that that that like subjects
like free speech subject like 2ms rights
what's what's happening
who are at least now a lot of people are
power they don't represent them but at
the same time I mean I concern myself
politically homeless and I'm always
looking for a home and I think that's
something like the new center would
definitely be my own people who believe
in and we can disagree on how much we
should tax the rich and I should have
universal health care or not I mean yes
we could have disagreements or that but
on the basic principles we all support
free speech and we all support
secularism probably women's rights is
something I would include there and
same-sex marriage and so on so I mean if
people would agree on these principles
definitely I mean I I I do consider I
mean you measure people like Ben Shapiro
I do consider them to be kind of very
more socially conservative than than
jahmai so I don't think that he is okay
with many of their values I think he
still believes in the judeo-christian
nonsense and all of these kinds of stuff
the reason I can include a guy like him
by the way is because when I've had him
here in my house just a few weeks ago he
said even though he personally is for
traditional marriage he said he doesn't
want the government to be involved so
even that I can take as a little win so
I don't mean we I'm with you we don't
all have to agree on every day I mean it
can be I mean I generally as long as
people agree on the concept of
intellectual conversation honest
conversation civil conversation the
concept of civil disagreements as
something I'm actually starting to value
so much because right now there's how
the concept of civil disagreement this
either you're a racist neo-nazi evil or
you're like a far left s communist
evil like there's happening like okay I
agree with you want some things agree on
some things and we can still be friends
and we can so probably for my political
party together I I really would value
that regardless of our maybe I would say
minor disagreements yeah I thought we
agree on too much this is how you change
the world brother listen it's always a
pleasure next time we're gonna do this
over beers or wine or something else
let's get it you shouldn't be smoking
cigarettes anymore by the way kosher
wine eighth grade I get you something
from Sonoma alright brother it's been a
pleasure talking to you and I'll see you
in a couple weeks Diego
alright ciao
you